S
DESPERATELY TRYING TO SQUASH A
PEACEFUL PROTEST.
BUT FIRST, IT'S ANOTHER FAST
RIGHT WING CONSPIRACY, AT LEAST
ACCORDING TO THE ALWAYS HONEST,
ALWAYS TRUTHFUL, ALWAYS ETHICAL
HILLARY RODHAM CLINTON.
TODAY, THE TWO-TIME PRESIDENTIAL
LOSER BROKE HER SILENCE AND
ANNOUNCED THAT THE DURHAM FILING
WHICH ALL BUT ACCUSES HER
CAMPAIGN OF, OH, KIND OF LOOKING
AT THE OTHER CAMPAIGN TO SAY IT
POLITELY, WAS FAKE NEWS.
PUSHED FORWARD BY FOX.
REALLY?
ACCORDING TO HILLARY, THIS IS
ANOTHER CASE OF OUR ENEMIES
TRYING TO SMEAR HER STERLING
REPUTATION.
"TRUMP AND FOX ARE TRYING TO
DISTRACT FROM THE REAL SCANDAL.
ED IS A DAY THAT ENDS IN A Y."
THE MORE HIS MISDEEDS ARE
EXPOSED, THE MORE THEY LIVE.
DON'T WORRY, IF THERE IS SOMEONE
YOU CAN REALLY TRUST TO GIVE YOU
IT STRAIGHT, IT IS
HILLARY CLINTON, RIGHT?
THE SAME HILARY WHO LIED ABOUT
THE PRIVATE SERVER, THE SAME ONE
THAT LIED ABOUT CLASSIFIED
MATERIAL ON THAT PRIVATE SERVER.
THE SAME HILARY THAT LIED ABOUT
WHETHER SHE WIPED THE SERVER
CLEAN.
THE SAME HILARY THAT LIED ABOUT
BENGHAZI AND ABOUT THAT TRIP TO
BOSNIA UNDER SNIPER FIRE.
THE SAME HILARY CLINTON WHO WILL
LIED ABOUT WHITEWATER AND HER
HUSBAND'S MANY TRANSGRESSIONS.
LET'S DRAW YOUR, SHALL WE?
>> THIS IS THE GREAT STORY HERE
FOR ANYBODY WILLING TO FIND IT
AND WRITE ABOUT IT AND EXPLAIN
IT.
IT'S THE VAST RIGHT WING
CONSPIRACY THAT HAS BEEN
CONSPIRING AGAINST MY HUSBAND
SINCE THE DAY HE ANNOUNCED
PRESIDENCY.
>> Sean: BILL DID IN FACT HAVE
RELATIONS WITH THAT WOMAN AND
MANY OTHER WOMEN APPARENTLY.
HE KNEW EXACTLY WHAT WAS GOING
ON AND SHE CHOSE TO LIE ABOUT
THAT AND SO MANY OTHER THINGS
FOR THAT IS BECAUSE
HILLARY CLINTON IS A
WORLD-RENOWNED LIAR OR
CONGENITAL LIAR AS WILLIAM
SAFIRE ONCE SAID.
THAT IS WHAT SHE DOES DAY IN AND
DAY OUT.
AND GIVEN WHAT WE KNOW, ASK
YOURSELF THIS QUESTION.
ARE YOU GOING TO TRUST IN
OFFICIAL COURT FILING FROM A